Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie et aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur " Rescuties "
Okkkkayyyyy
C'est parti on va attraper des bébés envoyez-les
Dans du papier bulles de préférence (blague)
Ooooooooohh oooooh Kirikou !!! (film pour enfant)
J'ai sauvé Kirikou !!!!!!
Oh p*tainnnnnn !
Ah une main par la peau du cul !!! ((mouha) bruit de bouche)
moa moa moa (bruit de bouche) Ah c'est bizarre merde...
Arrêtez ça va trop vite laissez moi le temps svp
Reste posé derrière le camion tu ne crains rien là-bas tu es à l'abri
de l'incendie
Je t'aime !
hop la ah m*rde oh !!!! (expression)
Attend je pense que je peux faire une tête attend ...
Ohlalaaa c'est Zizou ! Appelez-moi Zizou les gars (footballeur français)
Alors les chapeaux ça dégage ! [rires]
Attend il est immense ce bébé il y a un problème de proportion dans ce jeu hein je suis désolé
Des fois il y a des bébés mon gars c'est des adolescents
On ne sais pas ce qu'ils foutent avec une couche mais....
Ooooh ! Strike shot !
C'est fini ?
Rang C. J'ai fait un score de merde en même temps c'est parce qu'on était en difficile
donc du coup on va se remettre en facile... voilà ...
Okay c'est parti ! Cette fois on va se concentrer les gars
Hop ! Hop la ! [pleurs d'enfant] Et ouais mon gars c'est ça être pompier
Ha si j'ai pas le petit cadre...
Okay... sans le faire exprès ! Ca s'appelle un fight to win
Oh merde merde merde merde
MERDE!
Oh oh oh super violent !
C'est super dur de les attraper au passage
Non ça dégage ça c'est pas un bébé mec ! Vous m'avez pris pour un con ou quoi les collègues là
Pourquoi les rattraper alors qu'on peut juste les envoyer comme ça ?
Hein c'est vrai ou pas ?
Oh p*tain
Rang "F" ! Tout ça parce qu'on amuse à boxer les bébés
Puta**n
Suivant ! Je suis paré là !
Haa ! Haa! Attendez attendez pouce (=pause)
Pouce !
Haaaaa
J'ai perdu ma main ! Je suis tellement un pompier de ouf que jai réussi à perdre ma main
pour sauver des vies !
Pourquoi ??
Ah ça va aider ça au p*tain le con
Oh merde ! Ca multiplie les bébés !
Oh merde ! C'est quoi ce délire ???!!!
Je deviens fou les gars !!!
Non mais la on va perdre là  !!
Non mais ça sert à rien ça les divise
Okay okay okay
On arrête les conneries et on devient un pompier d'exception
(musique)
NON !!!!
OUI !!!!
OKAY AH ! Mes c'est quoi ce bébé mec ? Il rentre même pas dans le camion regardez-le
On en a sauvé 24 on en a perdu 24
Ça fait un bon ratio
Là ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on va faire le second level (niveau)
2ème level c'est parti. Alors là c'est quoi le délire ?
Oh mon Dieu le titanic s'est crashé il faut les sauver
Alors avant toute chose on va pas se mentir si on peut boire un peu d'eau
pour s'hydrater
Ça fait toujours plaisir
Okay maintenant balancez les bébés
Je vais vous sauver ça en moins de deux les potos (=amis)
Oh p*tain mais c'est un foetus c'est un embryon ce n'est même pas un bébé
Comment tu veux que j'attrape ça ?
Envoie ! Mais c'est abusé non ? Regarde ce petit truc !
Mais je fait quoi avec ça ?
Ah il faut que je les envoie là-bas
Tiens ton bébé !
Ça va plus vite !
Mais arrêtez il y a trop de choses qui se passent à la fois !!
Qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cette bouée ? On prend ?
Ha je me suis fêlé une cervicale
J'en ai marre de jouer à l'HTC je finis toujours blessé
Allez on se concentre. Fait péter les embryons !
Ah Ah Ah
Replay ...
Accident du travail !!!!
HAAAAAA
Je suis à genoux je continue !
Aidez-moi svp ! Oui la bouée je la prends et je me sauve !
Je me sauve avec !
[rires] Au revoir !
Adieu !
J'en ai marre de ce travail de toute façon je n'ai jamais aimé être pompier
NON
Mais c'est ça qu'il nous faut ! Pour bien envoyer
des bébés dans leur famille, c'est
ça qu'il nous faut ou pas ? Mon gars, on va
t'envoyer des bébés ! Malgré ce terrible
accident du travail et ses doigts fracturés
Squeezie le pompier retourna au travail pour sauver
la vie des pauvres petits enfants [boom]
Oooohohohoh p'tain le punch
Le prochain mec j'lui met un punch
Mouaaahahaha
Je crois qu'on a eu aucun bébé !
Je crois qu'on a sauvé que des.. AH
P'tain.. Oui, oui ! Oh l'embryon... Oooh oui !
[Bisou] hop là !
Voilaaa
On l'a rangé et je le kidnappe délicatement
Nan nan nan nan nan
AAh.. Pardon. [rires]
Nan mais les gars on est en train de péter le studio
Il casse son studio en jouant à l'HTC vive c'est ça le truc ?
Réflexe ! P*t**n !
Hé !
Franchement je veux bien sauver des vies, je veux bien accomplir
ma mission mais à  un moment faite un effort ! Okay
Ok ok ok ok...  On va refaire le niveau 1, les mecs
On va faire un score de ouf, sans regarder on s... on se.. On sait où
est le camion, il est dans notre mind (=esprit),
On a ouvert notre esprit... On est bon
Allez ! Faites péter !
Ah !
Aaah il est gros !
Ah ! Je peux plus bouger !
Je peux plus bouger il est trop lourd !
Aidez-moi ! On en a sauvé 15
On en a perdu 15 ? Merde ! Les gars...
Technique secrète, on va jouer avec le pied
Pour les envoyer...Ce sera beaucoup plus simple !
C'est parti ! Je mettrai une retournée. Attention retournée
acrobatique... M*rde !
Ooooooooh !
Ooooooh ! Ooooooh !
Ooooooh !
Vous voyez l'Euro ? (football) Ils auraient dû le gagner sur ça
Aller !
Merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette finale
d'Euro, victoire de la France sur cette incroyable
retournée acrobatique, in the... Truck
Ca veut dire camion en anglais, j'suis bilingue ! N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo
si ça vous a plu et je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine mission...
de pompier.
Ou une... Prochaine mission.. On s'en fout p*tain !
A très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, portez vous bien... Ciao tout le monde...
Peace !
/Merci à ceux qui ont participé aux sous-titres/